hopes his new board game called yuba
lingo will teach children the art of his
local language in an engaging way
fight effect
the nigerian board game designer who
lives in lagos is one of around 50
million people across west africa who
speak yoruba
if you
uh are trying to teach what people are
not really like excited to learn but you
have to take another approach so it's
like a fusion of entertainment um
education and entertainment so to form a
kind of entertainment background
ver learning something new that could
like spoil their excitement into trying
to you know learn the language and use
it more
several hundred indigenous languages are
spoken in nigeria
but nigeria's national institute for
cultural orientation says the nation's
top three spoken languages yoruba igbo
and hausa may not survive the next 50
years
adoramia dejbite a local artist who
promotes linguistic awareness says more
needs to be done to promote and preserve
local languages
for a long period of time in those
countries that were colonized the
colonizers languages have been
the former languages being spoken in
those countries in nigeria
quite a lot of initiatives are coming up
to protect
the languages and the violets you know
in
the country
the yuba lingo board game is set to hit
the market early next year with hopes
that it will reach children everywhere
jillian wolf al jazeera